- Oh, we're having pizza for lunch today.
- Hallelujah!
(claps)
(gospel music in background)
Hallelujah, this evening.
He's able. (claps)
Thank ya, thank ya!
- Darn it!
- What's the matter?
- My computer's not working.
- Oh, here. Let me help, let me help.
Heavenly Father, we upload this prayer
to you this evenin.
Delete the devil's cookies, Jesus.
In your name, amen.
- Amen?
- Give it a try.
- It's not working.
- Oh hey, Tracy. How's it goin?
- Oh, my brother, I will tell you.
I have been lied on, I have been cheated,
and just called everything
but a child of God.
But that's alright, you know why?
'Cause as long as I got King Jesus,
I don't need nobody else.
How are you?
- Fine.
- Alright guys, let's get started.
Can everybody kneel and bow your heads
for a word of prayer please?
Quickly, please.
Spirit of the living God,
fall fresh on this PowerPoint
presentation this evening.
- Hey, Tracy. Here's your paycheck.
- Offering plate.
- Okay.
- Now I want you to turn to your neighbor
and say "Neighbor!"
- [Group] Neighbor?
- God has blessed
these sales projections.
- [Group] God has blessed
- Amen, amen. Yes, he has.
That ain't nottin but God.
- Oh my God, Tracy, I did
something awful this weekend,
and I need to talk to someone about it.
- Wait, wait. Come with me.
- Where are we?
Can't we just talk normally?
- Yes, yes. Go ahead.
- [Woman] See ya, Tracy.
- Go in peace, and sin no more.
- [Woman] Did you build this?
Do you sculpt wood?
Tracy, how do I get outta here?
Tracy?
Is that my old desk?